THE STATE.
>> YES.
FINALLY, SEAN SPICER HAS A NEW
GIG.
HE WILL BE ON DANCING WITH THE
STARS.
GMA HAD FUN WITH THIS.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> SEAN SPICER WILL BE IN CHARGE
OF ASSESSING AUDIENCE SIZE.
>> OH, BROTHER.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> I ASKED SEAN ABOUT THIS A
YEAR AGO.
HE SAID THE ANSWER WAS NO!
>> HE FLIP-FLOPPED?
>> YES.
>> I KNOW HOW MUCH HE IS GETTING
PAID.
WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO TELL YOU.
CONTESTANTS FOR THE FIRST
EPISODE $125,000.
IF YOU ADVANCE YOU GET $20,000
AS YOU VANCE.
THE LAST PAIR 50 GEES.
HE COULD MAKE NORTH OF $200,000.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY DANCING WITH
THE STARS AT THE TABLE?
>> I USED TO BE.
>> WHY?
>> THEY RAN OUT OF REAL
CELEBRITIES.
>> IT WAS DOWNHILL AFTER TUCKER.
>> STOP ME IF IT EVER COMES TO
THIS FOR ME.
DO AN INTERVENTION.
THE ONLY REALITY SHOW IS LIFE
WITHOUT BRE
WITHOUT GREG WHERE I AM PAID NOT
TO BE IN IT.
>> I AM WITH YOU.
>> I WOULD RATHER DO 1,000 PRESS
BRIEFINGS IN A ROW THAN DO
SOMETHING WHERE I AM OUT OF MY
COMFORT ZONE.
WHEN I DID CELEBRITY JEOPARDY
FOR CHARITY.
I HAVE NEVER BEEN MORE NERVOUS
IN MY LIFE.
LIKE CRIPPLING NERVOUS.
>> MORE THAN A BRIEFING?
>> 100%.
I WOULD NOT BE GOOD.
>> JUAN, IF THEY CALL YOU?
>> I WILL SAY YOU WILL DEFEAT
RACIAL STEREOTYPES.
I AM NOT GREAT DANCER.
THIS IS A POLITICAL ARGUMENT.